fall is fast approaching and you know
what that means cooler weather
back-to-school sales and an updated
Netflix lineup to keep you indoors and
away from it all
September's heralding a galaxy's worth
of new programming for the streaming
service on the Netflix original side
we're looking forward to new seasons of
Bojack horseman and narcos plus a
handful of Netflix original movies and
an end of summer binge wouldn't be
complete without the upcoming true crime
satire American vandal here's an
in-depth look at everything coming to
Netflix in September 2017
narcos season 3 the DEA is setting its
sights at a new drug lord in the third
season of its addicting crime drama
narcos where the first two seasons
fixated on Colombian kingpin Pablo
Escobar the newest season will raise the
stakes even higher as the DEA launches
its operation against the Cali cartel
Pedro Pascal returns as DEA agent Javier
Pena delivering more the same gripping
real-life drama that catapulted the
first two seasons to critical acclaim
get ready to binge September 1st little
evil call is crazy but little evil looks
like it just may be one of the best
movies of 2017 starring Adam Scott and
Evangeline Lilly and written and
directed by Tucker and Dale vs. evil Z
like wreck little evil is a horror
comedy about a newly married man who may
just be the new stepdad to the
Antichrist
get set for big dark laughs when little
evil hits on September 1st resurface
with gorgeous visuals and a heartfelt
message about veterans struggling to
find their place in the world resurface
documents the journey of a suicidal ex
soldier who uses surfing as a way to
escape his physical and emotional pain
along the way he finds a community of
like-minded veterans searching for peace
among the waves experience the journey
September 1st Marc Maron - real comedian
Marc Maron has been making the world
laugh for years with his WTF podcast and
he's recently experienced a resurgence
on Netflix thanks to his role and glow
now he's dishing out laughs with a brand
new stand-up comedy special - real look
for its September 5th Bojack horseman
season for bojack's back and this time
it's serious sometimes other times it's
bound to be funny heartwarming
tear-jerking and poignant maybe a bunch
of those all at once because you never
know what you're going to pull out of
that bag
Netflix has been pretty quiet about the
details for the fourth season of Bojack
horseman so we'll just have to wait for
bojack's return on September 8th
reality hi nobody likes meeting their
partner's ex but things get extra hairy
when that ex happens to be a social
media starlet who's out for your blood
reality hi is a Netflix original comedy
starring Kate Walsh and winters and John
Michael Higgins it premieres September
8th green house Academy season 1
following two siblings at a boarding
school in California who find themselves
in the middle of a mystery green house
Academy star's Heartland Jessica amly
and newcomer Finn Roberts check out the
first season on September 8th the
confession tapes season 1 the first
season of Netflix documentary series the
confession tapes drops September 8th
focusing on convicted murderers who
claim to be innocent
if the confession tapes has received
half as well as making a murderer
it may be destined to become a new true
crime classic fire chasers season 1 what
if your day job puts you at risk of
being engulfed in flames on a regular
basis from the producers of Deadliest
Catch fire chasers follows the
firefighters who go face-to-face with
California's deadly wildfires to protect
the people in the fires path check it
out on September 8th Jeff Dunham
relative disaster tapes at a live show
in Ireland relative disasters chock-full
of Jeff Dunham's trademark mashup of
humor and ventriloquism get ready for
all new jokes all new hijinks and of
course all new puppets on September 12th
strong Island on September 15th Netflix
is adding to their docudrama selection
with strong Island a powerful look into
murder and racism on Long Island during
the early 90s diving into the real-life
story of a young african-american who
was murdered and the justice system that
failed his family strong Island isn't
for the faint-hearted strong Island is
one of the most intimately moving
portraits of racism in recent memory
strap in because these are stormy seas
and on the other end of the spectrum we
have American vandals season 1 the
trailer for Netflix American vandal
plays this story of mystery and true
crime hilariously straight despite its
simple premise someone at Hanover high
school someone nefarious to face the
school with a ton of hand-drawn dongs
it's the biggest mystery on campus who
doodled the doodles well the mystery
vandal ever be brought to justice and
more importantly will the wrong man pay
the price for the Peters find out in
September 15th first they killed my
father directed by Angelina Jolie first
killed my father is a historical
document during the time of the Khmer
Rouge regime in Cambodia the story is
told from the perspective of a five year
old girl struggling to survive the harsh
regime promising a gripping heartfelt
tale of courage and the strength of the
human spirit first they killed my father
premieres September 15th Jerry before
Seinfeld you don't become the world's
highest-paid comedian by sitting back
and resting on your fame and Jerry
Seinfeld's back in the saddle with a
brand new stand-up special the first
release in Seinfeld's 100 million dollar
- special deal with Netflix Jerry before
Seinfeld is as the name suggests all
about the early years in Seinfeld's
career before the hit show and before
the fame check it out when it hits
Netflix on September 19th fuller house
season 3 way back in September 22nd 1987
the first episode of full house
premiered on ABC and introduced the
world to the Tanner family now the third
season of the popular Netflix sequel
series fuller house is premiering
exactly 30 years later as revealed by
actress Candace Cameron Bure in an
Instagram post only the first nine
episodes are premiering on Netflix on
September 22nd while the second half of
the season will likely hit in late 2017
or early 2018 Jack Whitehall travels
with my father you may know Jack
Whitehall from a stand-up comedy or from
the comedy series fresh meat British
comedian joins the Netflix roster this
month with travels with my father the
series follows Whitehall and his dad as
they travel around Europe and try to
bond which goes about as well as you'd
expect with a goofball in a grumpy old
man a priest we don't say ëwell such a
little he would forgive me you'd
probably tell you to look for it in
September 22nd Terrace house Aloha state
part 4 if you haven't seen Netflix
original reality series terrace house
it's definitely worth a watch in the
vein of reality mainstays like the real
world the show throws a group of
strangers into a house together and
turns on the cameras while the previous
seasons took place in Japan aloha state
moves the action to sunny Hawaii dig in
for part 4 on September 26th jeralds
game adapted from the Stephen King novel
of the same name
Gerald's game stars carla Gugino and
bruce greenwood is Jesse and Gerald a
husband and wife whose vacation soon
takes a turn for the worse Gerald's game
is directed by Mike Flanagan who's
already garnered some serious street
cred in the horror genre with his
previous films like hush and oculus
check
in September 29th our souls at night
Robert Redford and Jane Fonda star in
our souls at night as two elderly
neighbors who form an unexpected bond
years after their spouses have died the
film is based on a novel by Ken terrif
and the story it tells is a poignant
glimpse of love and loss cue it up on
September 29th and keep a tissue handy
big mouth season 1 Netflix calls big
mouth a 10 episode half-hour edgy adult
animated comedy from real life best
friends Nick Kroll and Andrew Goldberg
about the glorious nightmare that is
teenage puberty if the pre-release clips
are any indication it'll definitely be
an odd show but it has plenty of comedy
heavyweights behind it other voice
actors tied to the show include Maya
Rudolph Jordan Peele Fred Armisen and
Jenny slate big mouth premieres on
September 29 club de Cuervos season 3
this comedy series mark Netflix first
Spanish original show when the streaming
service released the first season in
2015 and it turned out to be a pretty
good move with an 80% rating on Rotten
Tomatoes the first two seasons were
quick to pull in fans and now would be a
good time to go rewatch those seasons
because the third one is dropping in
September 29th the Magic School Bus
rides again
season 1 who could forget the Magic
School Bus
the classic nineties show that
entertained and educated well hold onto
your inner child because the Magic
School Bus is getting a reboot
according to Netflix the new show will
follow miss Frizzle sister and is slated
for a September 29th release new movies
Netflix is kicking off the month with a
ton of new movies along with a handful
of old favorites highlights include the
criminally underrated Brazilian crime
drama City of God Martin Scorsese's
hard-hitting epic ganks of New York and
Quentin Tarantino's stylish Pulp Fiction
all of which drop in September first
four new releases keep an eye off the
upcoming 2017 sci-fi action thriller
alien arrival about a soldier marooned
on an alien moon look for it September
23rd and you better believe you'll be
able to get your shark fix this month
with the entire jaws franchise and deep
Lucy also hitting Netflix on the 1st of
the month it's the perfect time for a
movie marathon if the Sharks will let
you
and if you want some good jokes Netflix
is loading up with all-star Comedy Jam
stand-up specials on September 1st
if stand-ups not your thing tune into
absolutely anything starring Simon Pegg
in featuring the voices of Robin
Williams and members of the Monty Python
crew on September 27th new documentary
releases include facing darkness coming
September 5th and goes to the mountains
available for streaming on September
13th and if you love music you can't
miss out on George Harrison living in
the material world an in-depth look into
the life and music of the former Beatle
directed by Martin Scorsese look for
that on September 15th finally what's
cooler weather without a cozy family
movie night pop some popcorn and settle
in with the kids because Netflix is
boosting their Disney selection this
September with the addition of Mulan and
Hercules in the first Pocahontas on the
14th and Beauty and the Beast on the
19th new television binging and your
favorite shows will be easier than ever
this month with a new season of the
blacklist hitting on September 7 The
Walking Dead on the 8th Gotham on the
21st and dark matter on the 25th of the
month and keep an eye out for final
fantasy xiv daddy of light a quirky
japanese series which chronicles a
father and son bonding over you guessed
it final fantasy now that's an
intriguing premise for the international
crowd Netflix is bringing on Star Trek
discovery the first Star Trek show since
Star Trek Enterprise wrapped back in
2005 discovery follows the crew of a new
ship called the discovery and it's set
about 10 years before the events of the
original series set your phasers to fun
on September 25th well everywhere except
the US and Canada that is most illogical
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]
you